[Musica]
ciao a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo monito io sono un po pj oggi sono
i pap la fortezza è stata fantastica
ragazzi ma chi mastica un minimo di
chitarra avrà capito subito che stiamo
facendo finta comunque ragazzi mi avete
consigliato give up in tantissimi mi
avete detto che me l'avete consigliato
sotto i video di cat mario quindi
immagino che cazzo di gioco sia allora
mi avete detto che genera il diretto che
lo scopo del gioco sta nel non cliccare
questo give up che poi non ho idea di
che cosa succeda comunque devo
praticamente devo andare avanti finché
il mio cervello regge c'è questo ho
capito perchè riesco ad andare a ma
finché non mi incazzo talmente tanto da
cliccare col tasto di merda l'aver primo
livello abbastanza facile
tanto ragazzi siamo a livello 8 ma
quanto cazzo sono forte l'obiettivo
arrivare a fare dieci minuti di video
tanto di sotto c'è il contatore e dieci
minuti di video senza morire modugno
niente ragazzi fate finta che io non
abbia detto nulla perché ho fatto un
file assurdo e ci sono sì no no no la
cosa bella visto gioco che non è come
che mario che ti far iniziare da zero ti
far iniziare i livelli sono abbastanza
accorti quindi c'è alla fine rimane
sempre così nello stesso punto c'è
adesso mista non bastavano le punte vi
sparano anche bene così allora vediamo
di chiarirci tutti quanti se man mano
che vado avanti nei livelli mi dovete
buttare la bomba di hiroshima addosso
ditemelo prima no no non santissima
ma come cazzo fate secco smart si può
ragazzi ma si può ho mollato il tasto
perché ora troppo eccitato di avercela
fatta e sono morto fantastico oddio
ragazzi non posso farmi salire il
nervoso così c'è credetemi ho una vita
una vita
braschi no no qualcosa ragazzi vi giuro
che se cliccherà mai viva per fare un
video in cui ballo in mutande
maledizione se cioè la quarta ragazzi
pian piano stiamo andando avanti cazioni
velici solito gioco meno di te cioè
fallin platform now ragazzi adesso
cadono le piattaforme madonna che pro
madonna che pro madonna non ci credo ma
come cazzo quattro ragazzi adesso cadono
perfetto come se non bastasse c'è devo
devo riuscire
io aver in grazia per il premio
conferitomi per il miglior giocatore del
mondo grazie mille
vabbè non dovevate ragazzi non dovevate
alla fine il talento
il talento e talento non ce n'è bisogno
di ricordarlo [ __ ] ragazzi si
accettano scommesse
provate a scrivere nei commenti in
quanto pensate che io riesco a fare
prima che è prima di premere give up ma
non lo prenderò mai perché io e tu sei
acqua dove anche saltare il tizio che mi
spa fantastico non bastava cosa che
crollavano cioè mi chiamano anche
rompere le palle così ma io il resto lo
stesso placa scrivete veramente nei
commenti a quanto pensate che io riesca
ad arrivare qualcosa mi dice che mi
ferma sto livello però fate impossibile
ok perfetto
io io dico 36 non lo so però tirato un
numero a caso così senza motivo un'opera
che ha tra l'altro dovete dirmi
[ __ ] no non dovete dovete dirmi
che io lo so che vi sono mancate stessa
eri e perché era da un pezzo che non vi
sentivate sclerare è socio e tutti ci
state godendo in questo momento lo so
perché vedete tutti i bambini
io prima o poi ci rimango secco di ciro
pino qui lo ammazzo quel cazzo anche se
non c'entra più niente che mario mimì mi
accanisco su di lui sempre non c'è
presto siamo alla 25 un buon risultato
ma si può ma ce la fai a saltare medi
bravo bravo così non è difficile allora
possiamo ragazzi fosse madonna che
dovetta è la prima guerra mondiale è
passato da un pezzo amici miei o per chi
cazzo mi avete preso per chuck norris ma
come faccio a farse cosa impossibile
c'è mio zio pacco che fa come si fa a
farsi livelli sì sì no no
sì posso fare ciò posso fare no no
[ __ ] ma non è possibile
i ragazzi lo sapete che io finita st
registrazione vado nei commenti a vedere
chi me l'ha consigliato un po il gioco
vero
voglio sapere chi è l'artefice di tutto
questo casino ma ce la posso fare nè
difficile si si io dire cosa c'è che
dire sì le lame che cazzo cech cena
mandatemi anche lei a sto punto no no to
do so se è ancora vivo sono curioso vivo
senza vivo sono ancora vivo non ci credo
inizia a piacere sto gioco ragazzi che
ci crediate o no mi piace mi piace da
morire mi piace da morire
si vabbè ma che cazzo era gamma ma
stiamo scherzando cioè io io veramente
stento a capire se è più difficile fare
sto livello o dire a mia nonna che non
lo fa me c'è una delle due
ma che cazzo no non è possibile un posto
fatti questa merda al centro di bello o
le folle e un mio dio non ci credo non
ci credo non ci credo ma non ce l'ho ma
ragazzi no ma non ci arriverò mai più
ma si sa ma non ci arriverò mai più ma
cazzo ma scherziamo
[Musica]
sì sì cazzo siete mio dio mio dio 499
morti da ancora una e uscivo falso
ragazzi non so quanta gente si è
suicidata questo gioco ma dubito che
siano in pochi come cazzo fatto non lo
so neanche io cos'è un muro invisibile
adesso ci sono non bastava tutto da
anche i muri mesi perfetto ragazzi voi
lo sapete ma si fanno talmente tanti
tentativi che quando ci si riesce
non ci si crede non ci segreti non ci
credo
devo rivedere melo troppo l'inizio visto
video e sfottermi da solo
no perché non avete tutto il giorno non
avevo idea di che cazzo forte che sapevo
che era un range game mar ma non che
fosse a questi livelli maledizione c'è
questa è una cosa impressionante
sì i 33 ragazzi già faccio
spinga spinga sta partorendo [ __ ]
[Musica]
io ci credo
ragazzi non ci posso credere ogni volta
che finisco sti maledetti male per male
che cosa ha detto vorrei ringraziare mia
nonna
il mio cane tutti alvin cane del vicino
e tutti coloro che mi sostengono
grazie grazie a tutti ragazzi è stato
difficile ma non è di casa
questa vittoria la dedico loro perché
l'antico vaso andava portato in salvo ma
porca put ero lì ero lì alla fine ero lì
se non ci fossero stimoli di merda
invisibili ci avrei fatti l'accusa temi
se mi sta esaltando ma io non vi dico la
gioia dopo 794 mor 795 796 797 morti che
cosa si prova a finire un livello
[Musica]
se cercate ragazzi se l'è cercata
inutile che tentate di difenderlo perché
è stato lui è lui che mi fa incazzare
colpaccio scommetto che lo stesso
creatore di cat mario il creatore di sto
gioco quello che volete
lo sapevo
ve l'avevo detto io che era colpa sua
una volta morto affogato non avrebbe più
fatto casino lo so quindi non ditemi
nulla lo sapevo già
comunque siamo arrivati al 36 37
così così senza motivo così mi sono
guadagnato il livello per cure in poche
parole cioè non so neanche come ho fatto
ma venite ucciso che domani e mi
riescono i livelli subito coincidenze
non credo praticamente arrivato due
livelli oltre a quanto avevo detto
quindi è un traguardo assurdo ci siano
ragazzi ci sono soltanto partito così
ma come si può essere così [ __ ] vm
avevo quota che sta a me ma vaffan
ragazzi assurdo sì sì sì no no no
[ __ ] ragazzi non si può fare se ne
va beh dai mettiamo un po più di
barriere invisibili
non lo so io sì sì sì ok ok ok ok calmi
calmi al mio dio ragazzi non ci posso
credere
non ci posso credere non ci posso
credere non ci posso credere non ci
posso credere
labitalia la vita non ci fossero non è
possibile
possibile allora vi giuro che ancora due
tentativi avevo intenzione di ficcare
chi va forte perché non pensavo
veramente di riuscirci non posso
crederci ragazzi ho finito di papua i
ragazzi mi piace per le b capitoli
assurda che non ha idea di come cazzo
più a farlo voglio ringraziare
nuovamente mia nonna e da miss italia
oggetto che sul grandissimo trofeo e
voglio la pace nel mondo
grazie mille ragazzi non ci posso
credere è stato assurdo ho vinto io
stronzi e vabbè ragazzo anzio schifo
che cos'è ai ragazzi stagioni giochi più
assurdi che abbia mai fatto ma l'ho
finito quindi se avete dei rage game da
consigliarmi tipo di bach vale sempre la
scommessa che se non riesco a farli
faccia un video motard e poi l'ho chiuso
dai più episodio per una volta
trionfante chiunque ragazze vito è
piaciuto come al solito sotto commento
mi piace anche la pagina di facebook e
come nani milo stradale funzione senza
vestiti iscrivetevi che ci rivediamo in
un prossimo video bene ragazzi